[Musique]
le Parti conservateur revendique que
d'ici 30 jours juste un trou d'autre
trouve une façon de fermer le chemin
Roxane ta question c'est pas est-ce
qu'on devrait le fermer la question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on a fait
parce que mettre des barricades au
chemin Roxon va tout simplement amener
les gens à traverser ailleurs à travers
des
6000 km de frontières qu'on a avec les
États-Unis
fermez le chemin Roxanne d'ici 30 jours
la demande du chef conservateur une
approche un peu simpliste dit Justin
Trudeau n'empêche le point de passage
régulier continue de faire la manchette
et mettre la pression sur le
gouvernement Trudeau pour qu'il trouve
une solution la visite de Joe Biden en
mars pourrait-elle mener à un déblocage
voyons voir ce qu'on pense mes
collaborateurs
de midi info et si première cette
semaine c'est Madeleine de Morin qui est
avec nous chef du bureau politique de
Radio-Canada Ottawa et Michel CEG
analyste politique à La Presse et
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour bonjour Adeline qu'est-ce qu'on
pense de ça l'idée de cette ultimatum
fermé le chemin Roxane dans 30 jours
livré par Monsieur paullièvre bien
Daniel j'entends que des libéraux qui se
en position de force façade de ce
dossier du chemin Roxane donc c'est pas
surprenant que Pierre poillievre les
remarqué lui aussi pierre Poilièvre a
démontré qu'il sait mettre le doigt sur
des bobos je pense par exemple à
l'inflation c'est lui qui a été le
premier à frapper sur ce clou là avant
les libéraux à parler de ça donc c'est
une chose de mettre le doigt sur les
bobos identifier des problèmes c'en est
une autre de proposer des solutions donc
de fermer le chemin Roxane c'est facile
à dire mais on fait ça comment est-ce
qu'on met un mur une clôture et c'est
quoi les conséquences ce qu'on entend
beaucoup c'est que les migrants seraient
portées à tout simplement essayer de
passer ailleurs dans des sentiers qui
sont moins sécuritaires moins balisés
plus dangereux et il y a un moyen où il
y a moins de contrôle finalement donc
c'est un problème que Pierre poillievre
a identifié je trouvais ça intéressant
aussi rapidement Daniel le fait qu'ils
disent et on peut utiliser cet argent là
pour que pour améliorer accélérer le
traitement des demandes régulières
j'entends que dans les communautés
culturelles ce passage au chemin Roxane
ça peut agacer d'avoir l'impression
qu'il y en a qui contourne le système
alors que avaient suivi les règles
avaient attendu le temps nécessaire pour
que leur traitement soit
traités leur dossier soit traité donc
voyez-vous j'ai l'impression que Pierre
poilievre essaie aussi
d'exploiter ce sentiment de frustration
chez les communautés
au Québec dans les sondages c'est pas un
Roxane Roxane n'est pas étranger à ce
phénomène là et on a l'impression que
les conservateurs ont un peu accroché là
dessus
absolument c'est pas de l'amour paupière
pollièvre c'est du désamour pour ce qui
se passe au chemin Roxane est-ce que le
gouvernement tarde à faire cela dit
c'est pas une solution il y a pas de
solution à ça cette histoire là c'est un
fait que vous fermez Roxane demain matin
tous les groupes d'aide au réfugiés
politiques de demain matin à côté on
pensait un kilomètre plus à gauche avec
des kilomètres plus à droite on va
peut-être en perdre une coupe d'en forêt
pour beaucoup plus avancés alors à la
fin il faut négocier avec les Américains
c'est long est-ce que ça s'appelle des
négociations formelles ou si ça
s'appelle se parler ça je ne sais pas
mais à la fin c'est la même chose il
faut parler aux Américains pour essayer
de trouver une façon de régler ce qui
est non seulement un irritable mais
quelque chose d'anormal dans dans le
traitement des réfugiés donc il faut
mais c'est long ces choses là c'est
jamais sec d'ailleurs Alec c'est
négociation c'est discussions avec les
Américains on a eu deux messages un peu
contradictoires la semaine dernière je
suis un Trudeau qui dit oui on jette
avec les américains puis l'ambassadeur
des États-Unis au Canada qui dure vous
avez pas entendu personne chez nous
parler de négociations c'est pas moi qui
va le dire non plus qu'est-ce qu'on
comprend de ce qui se passe là-dedans
qui disait quoi quelques semaines dans
les tout près d'une entente c'est
tellement fort qu'on était près d'une
entente
là maintenant c'est Justin Trudeau qui
dit ben on négocie fort fort c'est David
Cohen l'ambassadeur américain
alors je sais pas qui négocie avec qui
c'était des personnes différentes qui ne
se parlent pas c'est la comprendre mais
ce qui est certain c'est que les
Américains savent que c'est un héritoire
pour le Canada j'étais un truc nouveau
en parla Joe Biden quand il va venir au
mois de mars au Canada le problème du
Canada c'est que même si les Américains
savent que c'est un héritant ce n'est
pas en tête de leur priorité parce
qu'ils ont tellement de problèmes à la
frontière sud avec le Mexique écoutez
ces 200000 personnes par mois qui
franchissent la frontière avec le
Mexique au chemin avec Sam c'est 40000
pour une année ça me donne l'ampleur
différent du problème et il y a bien des
gens aux États-Unis qui voient le chemin
Roxane comme une solution pour les
États-Unis une soupape on laisse monter
des migrants vers le nord qui sont
actuellement à Chicago à Boston à New
York Philadelphie et qui met beaucoup de
pression sur le système américain
d'accueil des réfugiés alors ils sont
pas pressés de régler ça Roxane d'une
certaine manière ça fait leur Raphaël il
trouve ce plâtre pour nous mais ça fait
un peu leur affaire alors faudra trouver
de manière d'imposer le sujet trouver un
donnant donnant peut-être trouver un
sujet que les Américains voudraient
régler en disant mais régler l'entendre
sur les tiers d'un autre côté parce que
pour l'instant on sent pas les
Américains très précis de négocier ça
malgré effectivement le problème que ça
cause ici au Canada on prend une monnaie
de changement oui David Cohen
l'ambassadeur des États-Unis au Canada
n'a pas été très diplomatique dans sa
façon de parler pas très subtil alors
que Justin Trudeau venait le matin même
quelques heures avant de dire on est en
train de négocier l'entente sur les
tiers pays sûr on fait du progrès alors
imaginez après que l'ambassadeur vienne
dire c'est pas une priorité c'est pas ça
la solution il faut s'attaquer à la base
du problème et personne va confirmer
dans mon gouvernement ou à confirmer
dans mon gouvernement qu'il y avait des
négociations spécifiques là dessus donc
pas très diplomatique pas très subtil
mais Justin Trudeau ne l'avait pas été
non plus en disant que c'est ça la
solution renégocier l'entente s'implique
nécessairement les États-Unis de
renégocier cette entente là à quelques
jours quelques semaines de la visite de
Joe Biden au Canada ça pouvait coincer
un peu le président américain dans ces
dans des négociations qui ne voulaient
pas nécessairement avoir parce qu'on le
avec le disait bien le problème des
américains est tellement plus gros à la
frontière sud que c'est pas
nécessairement une priorité pour les
États-Unis la frontière nord et ce qui
se passe au chemin Roxane donc moi
j'avais vu l'ambassadeur utilisait la
stratégie du bon coq bat-cop lui faisait
le
mauvais code si on veut en attendant que
le président américain vienne ici puisse
peut-être parler d'autre chose
de cabinet du maire de Philadelphie on
forme des bas de corps parce que
vous assurer
belle façon on verra ce qui se passe
quand monsieur Binet est en ville si
vous le voulez on va attendre d'extrait
de François Legault qui lui était aussi
en négociation ça c'est des vrais
négociations en tout cas on les commence
et tu allais rencontrer son homologue
Internet et Labrador concernant Church
offert la centrale là-bas voici ce qu'il
a dit on a convenu
de commencer des pour parler
sur
les projets des projets futurs et on va
dans le cadre de ces discussions parler
d'avant 2041 et d'après 2041
[Musique]
alex je me tourne vers vous parce que
quand on a fait le bilan des fêtes l'un
des éléments que vous aviez soulevé
c'était le Québec doit négocier
Churchill Falls rapidement clairement on
vous a écouté
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui peut
ressortir qu'est-ce qui doit ressortir
de ça pour qu'on en arrive à cette
solution gagnant-gagnant là dont
monsieur Legault abondamment parlé la
semaine dernière d'abord Daniel je suis
content que vous rappeliez cet événement
[Rires]
c'est très intéressant et je vous dirais
que de manière générale
François Legault a eu une bonne semaine
parce que c'est lui qui a amené le
chemin Roxane sur la scène par
canadienne avec sa lettre à Justin
Trudeau belle-mère il y a une bonne
semaine dans la terminant à Terre-Neuve
et dans les deux cas il a eu le ton
sobre et ça lui va bien la sobriété on
n'a pas attaqué l'immigrants on n'a pas
dit qu'ils étaient dans des tout inclus
que c'était des profiteurs c'était très
bien fait on est arrivé à Terre-Neuve en
disant il lui ferry je sais que vous
n'aimez pas cette entente là et vous
avez raison d'être en colère ce n'est
pas une bonne entente pour vous
maintenant est-ce qu'on peut s'asseoir
et commencer à négocier sur une base un
peu plus d'égale à égale c'est ce que
les terre ne vient avaient besoin
d'entente ça c'est habile c'est bien
fait on n'arrive pas en disant vous
savez on est votre client principal vous
allez avoir besoin de nous de toute
façon non on est arrivé en disant
écoutez on le sait bien là ce qu'on
entend qui vous désavantage on peut même
rouvrir l'entente si vous voulez ah bien
potentiel pour un nouveau ferry en Terre
Neuve et Labrador rapide toujours bon
pour le gouvernement d'avoir des gains
rapides et non pas dans 15-20 ans donc
non je pense que c'est bien
[Musique]
que François Legault fait c'est de
penser à l'avenir donc après 2041
lorsque le contrat sera échu c'est sûr
que les prix vont augmenter donc est-ce
que ça voudrait la peine de rouvrir le
contrat tout de suite qui est à
finalement est allé un peu le
les soucis si on veut au lieu d'avoir un
augmentation majeure en 2041 si on est
capable de finalement rouvrir le contrat
et que ça fasse moins mal plus tard
c'est peut-être une option mais il y a
aussi toute la possibilité d'un
potentiel de nouveau barrage
hydroélectrique est-ce que peut-être
Hydro-Québec le Québec voudra se lancer
dans la construction d'un nouveau
barrage et ça se pourrait que ça soit
par exemple le projet de Gold Island et
ça il va falloir y aller avec la
collaboration de Terre-Neuve et Labrador
donc on est dans ce de ces grandes
discussions là donc c'est une première
pierre qui a été posée par François
Legault
un peu plus tôt une mission l'ancien
ministre de l'énergie qui tient il y a
l'entente au-delà de 2041 Michel mais il
y a aussi tout le potentiel
supplémentaire c'est aussi ça qu'il a
dans la Loriette monsieur le Gaulle
absolument et Monsieur cette semaine
dans ce dossier là où tout bon c'est
assez simple qui est arrivé à Internet
de façon très catholique en faisant un
acte de contrition mais c'est ça qui
fallait qu'il fasse il fallait qu'ils
disent on comprend que vous vous sentir
floué par ce contrôleur
c'est pas moi qui l'ai signé mais je
veux dire on le comprend maintenant on
l'accepte on est même potentiellement
prête à le réouvrir ça c'est c'était la
façon de commencer les négociations
l'autre chose c'est qu'une fois qu'après
le contrat sera reçu c'est clair que le
marché de l'électricité là ça reste
encore le Québec bon on pourrait
l'envoyer par carte sous-marin c'est pas
mal plus compliqué que l'utiliser au
Québec et l'expertise Hydro-Québec elle
est là et à vos chers on a vu ce qui est
arrivé à masquer
trois fois Terre-Neuve de la faillite
parce que ce petit démarrage là
avait des difficultés puisqu'elle était
en train il y a une commission d'enquête
mais alors donc pour un projet beaucoup
plus considérable
l'expertise d'Hydro-Québec elle vaut
très cher alors ça c'est du
gagnant-gagnant alors ça monsieur LEGO
est un homme d'affaires ici comment
mener ce type de négociation là et il a
débuté le processus cette semaine de
façon impeccable de façon efficace et ça
je suis d'accord avec mes deux collègues
je les
dit je pense qu'il ne faut pas minimiser
l'ampleur du ressentiment à Ternin et
Labrador le fait que François Legault
est dit on vous comprend c'est devenu
une mauvaise entente pour vous oui c'est
une pierre qui l'opposé mais je suis pas
sûr moi que tout d'un coup les terres ne
vient vont dire François Legault nous a
dit ça donc maintenant on est prêt à
négocier j'ai l'impression que même s'il
y a une entente qui est mise sur la
table qui est une entente juste des
terre ne vient vont pouvoir encore avoir
des doutes par rapport à ce qui est sur
la table donc c'est ça sera des
négociations qui seront difficiles pour
François Legault et pour le Premier
ministre Fury aussi qui va devoir faire
face à sa population face à cela
belle comparaison belle image pour finir
on verra si on en reparle au prochain
bilan à vous et moi à l'exercice d'avoir
été là cette fin de semaine c'est tout
le temps qu'on a
au revoir au revoir